There's one thing I know about the world. It's not the little things that matter, it's the tiny things.
OH, do you want a TINY piece of cheese?
Yes! Yes! Cheese is my life!
My name is Bella and this is how I met Lucas.
See those things. I really like you. Maybe that's a sign her home supposed to be
Don't choose shoes though, don't you shoot that one was his favorite
Over the years we did everything together good we chased squirrel
We went to work we even played a game called doctor doctor doctor gate
Again everything. All right. Yeah
Life with Lucas was the best but when he wasn't around I missed him so much that
squirrel again
squirrel squirrel squirrel
Duck looks like she needs help. Okay away the change
I was very far from home, but I knew Lucas was waiting for me and I had to go and find him
where needs
Oh, look. A snack.
Even better than a tiny piece of cheese.
We all face things that are hard. The only thing that gets us through it
are the special people in our lives, and I was NEVER going to stop searching until I found mine.
That dog saved his life.